even more troubling developments tonight
surrounding China as White House advisor
Peter Navarro reveals that China has
been caught cornering the market for key
medical supplies and actually
profiteering during the outbreak and not
only that drones being deployed to
surveil Americans amid lockdown orders
actually come from a company with ties
to the Chinese government Wow wonderful
interest making money off that -
interesting question right that was
previously suspected of by the way
spying on US citizens now the good news
is GOP lawmakers like Senator Tom cotton
congressman Crenshaw they are calling
out Beijing's lies deceit they have
introduced a bill that would allow
Americans told China accountable for
their virus response failures and of
course the Democrats their allies
state-run TV medium mob they continue to
spin for China and attack president
Trump shocker here with reaction Senator
Tom cotton congressman Dan Crenshaw
author of The New York Times best seller
fortitude good to see you both
congressman you haven't been on in a
while let me ask you about your suit and
to me the most revealing and and
dastardly evil thing that the Chinese
government did oh they saw how bad
Wuhan province was so they cut all
travel to and from Wuhan from within
China but they let the plains go out
internationally how nice of them exactly
five million people left Wuhan they they
they allowed this virus to spread they
knew it would spread they spread false
talking points like oh it won't spread
from human human contact they didn't let
scientists in to investigate you know
they they actually disappeared doctors
who tried to blow the whistle the number
of deaths and infections they had you
know when we when we dropped this bill
last Friday that was the same day that
the Chinese government said oh we
underestimated by about 50% the number
of deaths they didn't underestimate they
knew this is China they'd keep track of
every single person in Wuhan of course
they knew so now that we know how will
they have wronged us Americans are gonna
do what Americans do when we feel an
injustice is leveled against us we're
gonna find somebody I sue and so okay
true but I'll tell you what we also
something else they have a lot of our
debt
is costing this country senator cotton a
fortune I'd say they ought to forgive
that debt as it relates to the cost of
all of their mess that they caused yes
Shawn you and Dan had some good points
there about the evil intent of Chinese
leaders intentionally allowing this
powers to get outside their border you
also mentioned the hoarding of personal
protective equipment and now trying to
profit ear off of it or even sending
Chinese drones to America to collect
information and send it back China has
to pay for all of this one way to pay is
the lawsuit that Dan or the law that Dan
and I would have introduced would be to
allow American courts to hear cases
against China's leaders another one be
consider all that debt that China
currently holds given the fact that
we're gonna have two deficits financed
so much of the money that we're spending
to help float our businesses and help
our distress why can't we get we also
consider things like sanctions against
Chinese officials why can't we get the
PPP money passed why every time we try
to get a bill they try to change
immigration laws they try to change
election laws they want the diamonds for
the Arts and Humanities and the Kennedy
Center why can't we pass clean bills
help American workers businesses the
hospital's period and then not spend any
more money that seems like the Democrats
just don't want to take yes for an
answer here we've been willing to
support our hospitals support our small
businesses and our families how long the
Democrats keep as you say show there's
Nancy Pelosi one now straightness I
don't have it measures gated mansion
does she want more ice cream I'll send
her all the ice cream you can get on a
private jet fly back to Washington
safely leave a million dollar gated
mansion and I'll buy her a freezer and
I'll fill it with ice cream congressman
no it's it's infuriating we should have
been in Washington a week ago having a
non-controversial vote to simply
replenish the PPP funding we all know
that you know why they do this tion
because because the mainstream media
lets them get away with it the left-wing
media allows them to do it and so they
they don't tell people what's actually
happening so there's their supporters
simply say oh they mean well they must
have a good reason well they don't there
is no other side to this and it's really
gross
Senate should stage the session have a
vote every day Kevin McCarthy bring the
Republicans back wait I'll send all the
ice cream out that you can eat thank you
all